wie ihr wisst gibt es im deutschen viele
englische worte wir nennen sie
anglizismen anglizismen sind im
deutschen so populär dass sogar viele
worte gibt von denen wir nur denken dass
sie englisch sind in wirklichkeit sind
sie es aber gar nicht und hier sind für
euch zehn worte die im deutschen
englisch klingen und englisch
ausgesprochen werden
aber eigentlich gar keine worte aus dem
englischen sind der beamer ein beamer
ist ein gerät das bilder an die wand
projizieren kann das handy das hier
heißt auf deutsch handy das ding ist
zwar handy aber im englischen heißt es
nicht so happy end im deutschen glaubt
man dass der glückliche ausgang einer
geschichte happy end heißt im englischen
heißt es jedoch happy ending das
fotoshooting lasst uns ein fotoshooting
machen das korrekte wort in englisch
heißt allerdings fotoshoot der sprayer
jemand der graffiti-sprayer wie nennt
man den wohl im deutschen richtig den
sprayer trampen kämpfen heißt auf
englisch eigentlich headtracking im
deutschen benutzt man dafür jedoch dass
englisch klingende wort trampen der
streetworker die streetworkerin als
streetworker bezeichnet man im deutschen
interessanterweise einen sozialarbeiter
der sich mit gefährdeten gruppen auf der
straße beschäftigt zum beispiel mit
obdachlosen oder mit jugendbanden im
englischen gegen ist streetworker vor
allem ein begriff für prostituierte sehr
oldtimer als oldtimer bezeichnet man im
deutschen ein historisches auto oder ein
historisches motorrad im englischen
heißen sie jedoch vintage cars oder
klassiker ist der hometrainer als
hometrainer bezeichnet man im deutschen
ein sportgerät wie zum beispiel ein
fahrrad oder ein laufband dass man zu
hause stehen hat
im englischen gibt es diesen begriff gar
nicht public viewing wenn man in
deutschland mit möglichst vielen leuten
draußen auf einer leinwand ein
fußballspiel sehen will dann geht man
zum public viewing im englischen wird
dieser begriff jedoch meist in einem
anderen zusammenhang benutzt nämlich bei
der aufbahrung eines toten